Challenges yes.
Challenges from them
but there was a time i think it was perhaps
five six maybe even seven years ago.
It appeared that the.
The whole smack scene was getting out of
control in the streets in the manikin you
know and then that that it seemed
to go through a period of.
Easing off i don't know if economic
conditions in the outside world have an
interview with the fluctuating number
of junkies that seem to come to town.
It appears from what i've heard to be
going to another upswing right now.
I mean it's obviously a shame for the
people who work in the mine to shame people
who are on the smack to you
know shame for everyone
but i don't think it's it's anything
that will drag the town under
and see the town becoming because it sounds
just like a visual manifestation of a
lot larger corps of people you know
and there are thousands of people you
never see in the streets of town
that are out in the hills
that perhaps don't shop in the main
because i don't like the in-town feeling
but they're still around.
I don't i can't see any real
challenges that nimbin can't succumb.
I think the tourist challenge is perhaps
the biggest one we've faced yet in a lot
of ways
and a lot of people who are very strongly
about it you know very anti tourist don't
come staring at us. So i think we're
just living our life piss off.
I don't want a few tourists.
That's what we are if we
go overseas a challenge.
Yeah i can't see anything that
that's going to bring us down.
We'll just go from strength to
strength. Take over the world.
Nim into day tomorrow.
The universe to pleasure.
Okay.
My most fun celebration by bob is.
The one that really sticks in my
mind was the house warming party
that we gave when with
finished building our house.
Don and myself and.
We'd planned our house warming of at
least six months before it happened
and.
Had a very optimistic attitude as to how
long it would take us to build this house
that we were building.
Having never wielded hammer
and sold before in my life
i didn't own any tools
and i had a buy my first hammer and
so when i wanted to build a house.
And we do this house we'd had a fiat little
bit of a problem with the council in
terms of forgetting to
contact them first about it
and he had issued us the stop work notices
only weeks before the party was due.
But
when it eventuated the they had we'd moved
into the house 24 hours before the party
and had no furniture had
nothing in the house at all.
And maybe one hundred fifty people turned
up out in the middle of nowhere like
to me it seemed like it was right
in the middle of the bush.
There was no other houses you could
see first far as the eye could see.
And there were all these people in my house
and everybody had brought a cushion.
And it was just wonderful. I
went for about two days. And.
Stuck in my mind
and stuck right there in this image of this
wonderful party was his close friend of
mine who had just got out of hospital two
days before after being in traction for
six. A month with a broken
hip from a car accident
and he sat in the one
arm chair that we had
that somebody had brought
an arm chair for him
and he sat in his chair all all night
and most of the next day with a big smile
is life. And it was just wonderful.
Diana had made some rather
overly strong cookies
and everybody had a really wonderful time.
To do what it's so great. Oh yes.
I love of a good party.
I think is the common thread and
the the bonding that people get
when you have a really big happy successful
celebration together you know it's
there it's the old farm
is greater than the all
that the whole is greater than some of
the parts of i was trying to say is that
when there's a group get
together to celebrate
and it's a good working celebration
it seems to achieve something you
know that that feeling of unity. I think
that a lot of people need to continually.
Reassert and reestablish that feeling
of unity with their kindred spirits.
I think that's perhaps one of the
binding forces in the area is
that feeling of kindred spirit
when the people who are here.
Hi i'm jill. Jill jones and i came here.
19 actually went away
for a couple of years
and then came back to live
permanently in eighty two.
I think it was
when my son was old enough to go to school
he needed a bit of a base and before
that i was a travelling hippy and.
Now i've found after living in the bush
and having babies and building houses.
Which i've loved to do and
growing vegetables and all
that it's now i've needed something a
bit more creative to find meaning in my
life with if you like.
So i've established a fabric painting
business which i really love to do
and it's brought me
closer to a lot of people
and i've been able to share my skills with
a lot of people in nimbin get some of
the kids a bit more inspired and but more
motivated into doing something creative.
Which makes them feel really
good about themselves.
And i've got a great shed
that i work and from home.
Which is i'm very lucky i'm one of the
few houses here that's got mains power.
So i couldn't do it otherwise it irons
and over lockers and that sort of thing
and
and attracts a lot of people here into the
community of diverse people i've had a
woman from the gold coast in fact yesterday
who came down who's interested in
marketing some of the gear
and it's really interesting
to have a focal point like
that to attract all these
sort of different people.
And it's a good meeting point
and it's also good for the you know the
broader area to have a bit of an economy.
You know and. You know being
able to generate money
and also the tourists coming into the area
there are all wanting something unusual
to take away with them and there's very
few things all that's getting more
and more products in the shops for
people to buy and take away so
that that's a big part of it as well.
As well. We live. Yeah.
Living in the bush.
I mean you just look out the window
and it's just so inspiring this
and it's all so new in the so
much diversity and patterns
and colours within the
people the environment.
It's the conversations
that you have it's all feeding you constantly
i often thought if i move back to the
city. I don't think i could be
as creative because it sort of.
It sucks you i think whereas
here at nourishes you the bush
and there's always different ideas
and different color schemes you know
on a wet day i'd tend to do so.
Grey blue purple he colours and on a
hot sunny day it's all red and orange
and yellow. Yeah.
About.
Yeah i came here with a three year old at
first he hated the city because we lived
very when i lived in new zealand we didn't
have we didn't believe in any money.
We live totally sustainably we used to
pick mussels off the rocks and sell them
and sex once a month we had a
boat and the money we made from
that we bought sex of rice
exit wheat and sex of sugar
and we used to fish in those
wild pork and those cry fish
and we had an incredibly abundant life
we from the land. That's all we we used.
What was around us and
when i first came to nimbin from new
zealand i couldn't believe coming to them
bingeing nobody had vegetables
in the ground like i thought.
They're just playing at being
a alternative you know
and it took me awhile to get used to
that i mean the australian government
and its magnanimity
or whatever the word as just paid us to
live here in paradise so i thought oh well
that's ok. I thank you very much.
And now i can get into other things
apart from growing vegetables
and you know doing the basics and i think
we've been very very lucky for years
and i don't know how long it's going
to continue but i think it's something
that we've all got a look at that
it's not going to keep going forever
and we do have to create
another economic base
that there's no this
area can sustain itself
and that's one of the challenges i guess
that i can see for number one in
terms of creating a different akon.
Maybe based not on what mainstreams based
on but more viable in the sense of.
Like you know the whole permaculture
thing the whole gamut vegetable.
Thing and with the arts
as a lot of tourists
and a lot of visitors
coming to the town that it.
You know they really want things
and they're going to waste it with money
in their pockets and empty handed.
So you know there's a very there's a
really big market and there that has to be
that would be good to tap
into in a positive way.
Is possible. No because
survival as very hard.
That's what i found in new zealand for
three years survival was number one
and you didn't have time. I mean
we had a beautiful. We had.
You know our lifestyle was fantastic.
What we ate what we talked about
the music we had and all that
but it was very much of a struggle.
You know 24 hours a day virtually you were
working all the time whereas i think the
dole has given us the freedom to
well build nice a comfortable houses
and it's given us a time to go off
and you know create more interesting things
to do rather than just the toil of who
you know.
Happy dole bludgers yeah well
i think yeah be dull that.
I feed as a rural subsidy.
And i see a lot of people
doing really worthwhile
and potent things with the money
that we get while building a house for
example rather than being tapped into the
mortgage belt for 40 years or whatever.
However long people get tapped into.
And yeah it's like a subsidy to say ok
you know like you can populate this area
but after a while i think
inherently you know
when you've got everything pretty
well set up then it's time
that we've got the freedom we
have got the financial pressure.
You know that we can create these new.
Little industries dotted
around the countryside
and that's the way i see no developing
with a whole lot of small business
and really creative dynamic
things really interesting things
that people can get
involved and feel excited
and happy about rather than 40
hour week you know five grand
that most people sort of see as what the
rest of the world are doing most of
western society anyway.
Away in a circle.
Because the way people live in poverty
mentality is very strong here.
I think a lot of people came to the nimbin
area to run away from the 8 to 5 grind.
And there is a lot of faults and that
but at the same time it doesn't mean
that all workers bad or money is bad
that there is another way we can create
money there is another way we can work like
the way i work you know we have a lot
of fun. It's all about fun and ok.
Some days you don't feel very productive
and you don't be as productive
but we did you just keep going and then
another day comes along and we're all
and spas and creative and we
produce fantastic things.
Yeah.
And i think the quality of life is what we
all we all came for here for the quality
of like bob was saying before the quality
of the union of people getting together
and you know we talk about really important
things we talk about personal things
that are affecting us rather than
you know what you bought last week
and what you're going to buy tomorrow
and what video you watch last night you
know people talk about their feelings a lot
of people talk about.
You know ok we get into broad overviews
like the kids the other night they were all
here my teenage you know jake
is 15 and a few of us friends
and they were talking about black holes
and the universe in the multiverse
and physics and chemistry
and all the new scientist of science stuff
that's happening all over the world you
know in western new science circles and.
A lot of the kids and a lot of
adults were into very sort of broad.
Intellectual diversity if you like here
and i think that's because we live in such
a raw environment we've we're not like
if you lived in europe where there's been
people living for the houses of years
you'd sort of the somehow infiltrates
into a very bones of the be you know your
very being. And that's
what everybody thinks
and talks about whereas
here it's all very new
and it's this whole new age is incredibly
strong and people's conversations
and how they dress how
they express themselves.
And all that sort of a sense of
some cut off from the rest of the.
Well i've been here so
many years and that's
when i get out there like go down
to the city. I think oh come on.
I think you know the world changing
everyone's you know it's getting better
and i go out there. I think oh i think
i live in a little coon up here.
I think there is a sense of we are a bit
separate and different from everybody.
But i think like this gold coast
woman that. Came the other day.
She's really waking up and talking
about sort of new age stuff
and i think it's happening all over.
I think nimbin is a real nucleus of it
and i think the rest of the world slowly
followings like health foods you know ten
years ago nobody had a muesli
was everybody eats it now
and we've been eating it for 20 years
and brown rice and tofu and all that
and i think we are a bit of a yeah
a bit of a leader and terms of.
Lifestyle and food and
all that sort of thing
and via mental issues of course that's
always been top of the priority list in
terms of people creating more sustainable
ways to live to people support.
Personal interaction
that way.
It's been a lot of relationship as
you know everybody is living after.
Well i don't see it as a negative thing
i've i say i don't see i think all the
relationships
that are going through really hard times
at the moment in the last few years.
I see it as it will grow a challenge
i think it is a real growth.
Thing for growing you have to really look
at yourself you've got to look at so many
different issues rather than just hanging
in there was putting up with things
that aren't you know good for
you and aren't good for kids.
I think we all tend specially with the
women around here we all get together
and talk a lot about our personal stuff
and relationships and that sort of thing
and i think it's we all grow and we're
all a lot more compassionate and wise
and more capable of having.
Better quality relationships
than you know the average person
watching the pressures of life.
The pressures from living this way
or living in a quite difficult.
I mean to you know how difficult thing to
do those pressures i mean the fact i mean
you know i think for people living
together 24 hours or so years
when people break up around here it's you
know we've we're living in each other's
pockets 24 hours a day seven days a week
and i think you do tend to get
a bit sick of each other.
Plus the whole struggle of
surviving you know building houses
and having babies at the same time
living in tents in the wet season and
when you used to the old color t.v. In flush
toilets which we most of us came from.
It's really really hard
and then you often find with your partner
they they're quite happy to sort of live
in a tent for four years whereas of us women
especially with babies you just don't
want to keep doing that. So yeah i
think it created a lot of tension
and relationships and just
the hard yakka the hard work
and then there's the whole feminist the
whole sort of six sexist role battle
that went on like all the men.
Now there with a chainsaw
and fixing the cars
and the women looking after the babies
and people feeling a bit sort of
stuck in their roles and you know
that sort of thing i think
it created a lot of tension.
Sort of born out of necessity. As role.
About. I see males and
females as being different.
And here are they not better not worse.
I think some women love
might love fixing cars
and using chainsaws other men
like looking after babies
and cooking in the kitchen so.
Lost that there is one but
when there are advantages in living
in a community like this for you.
There's a single using my. I have been
for the last three or four years.
Oh look at fantastic living on a community
is always somebody look after you kids
or you know you can always share
the whole parenting role.
And for other kids you know
fishy when they get older.
I've had a few coming in and they
need to talk about their problems
and they can't talk about
it with their parents so.
You know for the kids there's a lot more
adult interaction that they can get
and they can get their needs met a lot
more from other adults rather than just
their own parent. Give us. The way we can.
Yeah well there are a lot
more most. You know.
Yeah well most of the kids seem to be
really comfortable with other adults
and they like and walk into a room
with adults and feel quite comfortable
and so there they come to our parties
and they're not so shuffled away
and they're very much part of the whole
lifestyle here they're integrated
and i think that's really
really healthy i mean
when i was a kid you
know any visitors came
and your shovel out the back door
seen and not heard sort of thing
and i think it gives them the kids here
a lot more life skills in terms of
communicating and what
they want and they can.
There are a lot more compassionate about
people with problems i mean we've had
quite a few people
that nimbin gee you've had a few
problems sort of mental problems
and the kids just observe it.
And there are a lot more
equipped to deal with people
when they're older than you know sort of
just had their own adult parents to relate
to one of the downsides things you.
The downside the kids here.
I think the media they often watch you
know happy families on the telly like the
cosby show and all that and
there they are there videos
and there you know all there is and they
come back and they've got brown rice
and candle light and. And i often
think that you know a few years ago.
We're all worried that all our
kids were going to go off
and want to be yapper eastern policemen
and lawyers and things like that.
So you know with the
external world stepping
and i think in a lot of our kids minds
that creates they're not so happy.
I'd rather have what they see on the telly
but as they get older i think they realize
what that what they've gained here and.
You know it's not such a big
gap that they see the change
and come up one way to
get yeah yeah well at
the moment this is one of my things.
There's not a lot for the kids to
get into there's no not much work.
It's you know it's a real petting the nimbin
high school put in a submission to go
on to 11 12
and it was knocked back for the life of
me i cannot understand why there are so
many kids coming up to that age.
They've all got to jump in the bus
and go on to lose more and back them
and school is going to offer a lot of
diversity in terms of the schooling hours
they could pick and choose when they
came and went a lot of interesting.
You know like the wood work and
metal work and the it's all
that sort of thing was going to be very
strong personal development subjects were
going to be strong as
well as a chess see and
that was a real blow to me to a lot of kids
a lot of kids are going to leave school
two years before they really should
or cause you know 15 16 year not very
mature to cope with what they are out there
rather than when you say 17 after
you've been through the system.
So that's a real pity but i just see
for a lot of the kids that they have
and it's slowly happening but we need
to provide more work experience more.
For them to tap into when they get older.
Those you know rather than
having to go to the city
or just to sit around on the
dole and they finish school.
That's very important here now
and the so i mean i don't
know what the statistics are
but the so many kids now coming of age
from you know the 70s that's what 18 years
ago. We've got to leave a 10 year old kids
that were born from the aquarius time
and they all really need
something to to key and to.
So that's that's a real
challenge from them then.
And
that me is a real high priority.